hey guys I'm back with David pac-man and
we're knocking out some of our favorite
stories of the week I saw this on
Politico an interesting story about how
Millennials get the news a huge
percentage of you guys are Millennials
that means that your pac-man what does
it mean they're basically under 25
no but millennial in Irbil I think all
the way back to born in 1980 I think
still counts is the cutoff so what's
interesting here mostly I think is that
61% of Millennials which is a incredibly
high number are getting their news on
Facebook it's a little bit less for the
old-timers like me at 51% and for baby
boomers which is you know the the 52
probably 75 is crowd right now they're
still getting the bulk of it on local TV
but the first thing that popped up in my
mind when I was looking at this though
was this thing about catered news and
how we're catering news to ourselves
constantly on Facebook is the ultimate
example of this right because you're
friends with people that usually like
the things that you like you're
interacting with people who probably
have mostly the same political beliefs
is you so it seems to me there's some
inherent risk of us all just getting
this like really catered small piece of
information instead of a whole picture
you think no I mean the thing I thought
of when I saw this is there this study
has options for where you get your news
that are not necessarily equivalent in
the sense that for example getting your
news from MSNBC versus getting your news
from Google News are not the same
because Google News is is mostly an
aggregator so when I saw all these
people are getting their news from
Facebook Facebook isn't reporting
anything what it is right your Facebook
friends and the algorithm are making it
so you can click on articles from other
news sources so in a sense Facebook has
become like a news curation service
right but isn't that the risk though
because you're mostly gonna get news
curated to you that only gonna reinforce
what you believe because you're probably
friends with people that believe similar
things yeah unless you're me in which
case it seems everybody
my facebook hates me but that's a
different story yeah no you're
absolutely right it sort of reinforces
this echo chamber that that already
exists we see people who watch Fox News
other than those like me who check it
out to see what insane thing is
happening over there so I can critique
it are doing that because it's already
sort of the the type of mentality that
they sympathize with so yeah there's
certainly that risk the other element of
it is that aside from the Facebook
algorithm showing stuff you might
already be predisposed to like or that
your friends like is whether Facebook as
a curation service has any kind of bias
and that would be a sort of other
conversation right so we don't know how
they do their algorithm
I guess the bigger part here is that
young people Millennials just simply
don't trust mainstream news which that
in itself I think is pretty good because
mainstream news is pretty awful isn't it
guy who's on the internet doing news
yeah and I refer to it now as corporate
media because it's really you know you
can have a corporate media outlet that
chooses to take a more liberal editorial
point of view like MSNBC or a corporate
media outlet that like Fox News says
we're going to have a more conservative
editorial position but you're still
talking about that corporate media
machine that's tied in directly with the
elected officials and with their
advertisers and it's this whole sort of
incestuous circle that we've pointed out
right so so us as online people we we
suffer from another piece look they're
getting their money from the very people
they're supposed to be covering and
that's obviously a huge problem everyone
understands that for us we have to get
clicks like at the end of the day not
only to repaid by clicks on YouTube it's
very low I don't want to get into that
right now because it'll make you it'll
make you cry but we have to get clicks
like it's as simple as that
so then sometimes you might cater your
stories and curate your stories in such
a way that are gonna get you more clicks
as opposed to doing stuff that you think
is purely relevant right sure there's a
line and I've had this conversation you
know when I did gamergate stuff and you
and I have talked about gamergate
coverage someone decided to accuse me of
clickbait with my titles and then it's
spread like wildfire where all of a
sudden it was all David Pakman does
clickbait titles and
actually had this conversation with a
with someone who was critiquing me and I
said so let's take a step back here are
the titles inaccurate do they not
represent what the what the video is oh
the titles do represent what's in the
video so what you're saying is I'm
cherry-picking the most interesting
elements of a video to put in the title
so that people will watch it that you
know we can have the conversation of
whether something is overly salacious or
what-have-you but to me that's a very
it's much less concerning than hearing
that I didn't cover a story because I'm
paid by a certain company right that
that's just horrible sure sure and by
the way to your credit with that whole
gamergate thing and we did discuss it
once on your show I wanted to start
covering it was such a deluge of
insanity and misinformation and
confusion that I was like you know what
this is I just can't handle this one
yeah actually you've done a really nice
job of it what do you think about you
know I have a firm belief that you know
because of the corporate media and the
mainstream media controlling everything
for so long that there was a couple
years probably about five years ago five
or eight years ago where the online
media became incredibly important
because it was we were finally getting
this alternate voice what I see
happening now is absence everyone can
have a voice which is the
democratization of the Internet and it's
really great but because of that there's
also no fact-checking anymore so
everything that's online is pretty much
not fact checked it's fact check maybe
by the commenters but you know we're not
we're not held to any standard I tell
the truth the best I can and I source
everything the best I can but I also
think there's some risk in everyone
talking about the news where there's
just nobody to really ego well here
there's nobody trustworthy enough I
think at this point to go well here's
actually what the facts are what do you
think about yeah that's an issue and
this this you know anytime you have a
sort of new platform it takes a while
for the public at large to sort of
synthesize how it is that they should be
interpreting or understanding it it's
kind of like if you were to go back to
when you had to go to the movie theater
to get the news headlines from what was
going on in the war if you were to walk
into that room and just give someone a
tab
and have a video of Alex Jones or
something like that their understanding
of how to interpret the sort of validity
of Alex Jones would be mostly determined
by their understanding of the news they
were getting in the movie theater so
that's I think there's something that's
going to play itself out and you already
start to have reputation systems and so
on which help to discern and let the
better stuff rise to the top hopefully
anyway for sure and that's why I always
like talking to you because I know you
do your research and you're telling the
truth and I'm sure you've fact checked
yourself once or twice right yeah if I
made a mistake
I will correct it as soon as possible no
question about it now we're there there
are sometimes disagreements is when
people can't distinguish between a news
and an opinion show and this is just the
basic media literacy issue that we have
in this country where people will write
to me and they'll say David I like you
because you're less bias than Fox News
and I say you fundamentally don't
understand what I'm doing because that's
not that's what you're talking about a
different barometer I do an opinion
program not original reporting right and
that is the interesting thing because
everyone seems to want opinion
programming right that's what people
seem to be watching personality driven
stuff that's usually based in bias at
some level often and often they admit it
right if you're working for MSNBC
obviously you're on the left and if
you're at Fox you're obviously on the
right but I think it makes for an
interesting piece for the for those of
us that are online and are trying to
bring this and I think I like the fact
there